Hello, Kyle.
Hello!
Well, how you doing?
I'm doing good. How about you?
Not too bad.
I don't know which on which teams do I pull in Mark. Is it on F12 or ITBD?
But.
Looks like you jumping in on F12.
Mark, I was... Mark, I was going to call you. I was just in a jeopardy where I was thinking whether I should call you on F12 or ITBD.
Yeah.
All good.
Both, we can see him twice.
Okay.
Yes, that's right. I ran away from Seamus. That's what I did.
Yes.
But.
But...
Yeah.
Nah.
Seamus is not respecting your boundaries again, Mark.
Yeah.
Nah, nothing like that.
I never do.
Yeah.
Okay.
And when I see you, Natalie, I and Kyle together, I was thinking of a time when Lakhwinder visited and I feel like it was just yesterday. However, it happened in January, but I still get the feel and everything like, yeah, this happened in last month only or so.
Yeah.
How quickly the time passes and it's almost May and half of the May is gone so.
No.
Be.
Yeah, it's almost, it really feels like yesterday that Manuj was asking Chili's to turn the music down.
Ohh.
Yeah.
Why do we have to go to that that point?
Okay.
I just thought it was funny. It's all loud in here, Chili's.
Das.
Yeah, so Chili's is an international chain, correct? You have there in US and Canada as well.
Nah.
Yeah, yeah, we have Chili's. Yeah, actually, my son, his friend works at Chili's and like he's back for college, so he has to get a summer job. He may work at Chili's. I was like, honestly, I could go for that. I could, I could be a Chili's mom.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Right.
If.
O.K.
Cool, Seamus, what do you got for us?
Yeah, ohh.
Let me share my screen.
OK, thanks everyone for joining. Agenda stays the same, nothing changed. But before I proceed, I am really happy and relieved because of two things. First of all, Manuj was able to take.
Mm.
three days leave along with this week off. So I'm really happy because he spent some time for him personally. I really love that I've been working alongside Manuj for last three years. I've been very close to him in person, so I know.
What, what?
Yeah.
Yes.
how much he is dedicated towards work. And this three days leave was really important. And secondly, when Manuj came back, I asked him.
How was the trip and everything? He said good, exhausting and all those things. And then I asked for work and he clearly said like, no issue schema. That was the second big point that I was able to hear. So yeah, team is becoming self-dependent. So that is really good.
Yes.
Manu just taking the team in the right direction.
Yes, yes.
Manuj, did you go on a trip for your for Mother's Day, taking good care of your wife?
Yeah.
No, he went with other boys.
Yes, yes.
No, you what? It was a boy strip.
Yeah.
No, no, no, it.
I've always given more crap because one time, was it her birthday? And I was like, did you get her a cake? Or the cake, or you ordered it too late or something so she didn't get a cake? I don't remember.
Yeah.
Nah.
Yeah, long live Swiggy, Zomato, or Uber Eat, right? They save the day. That's what I say. But yeah.
But.
There you go.
That's cool though. Probably on your motorcycle though.
Okay.
Yep.
Kaila.
Yeah, well, Mark was away. I just kind of creeped on the on the team. I wanted to see how they would handle everything on their own without actually stepping in and like actively checking them. I just kind of kept an eye on the chats. Didn't say anything, just watched them, made sure nothing was going sideways.
Mark's got them set up for success, though.
There you go. That's awesome.
Okay, good job, Mark. And let's start with the highlights. So Hector has joined as a replacement for Neil. Mark informed like he's catching up quickly, so that's going good. Operational improvement, if operational improvement, if I talk about like call handling discipline, that's going well.
Yeah.
Mhm.
and Manuj is doing weekly review, sharing details with the team. So that's going good. So when the team is seeing the numbers and everything, they really know what needs to be done. And over from January through April and these last four months.
We have seen that the missed call percentages have gone down.
That's really good. We changed the model to 24 cross 7. That's working really well. We now have shift leads defined. So that's also a good thing from Manuj. He took that step and he defined the shift leads. So that's good.
And that's where he can shift his responsibility to the team. That's a very good point. And.
Mm.
improve call responsiveness, the calls are being handled better and there are no extended shifts that are being there.
That's good. So moving, so the biggest motivation that I see in the team and the biggest change is moving out from 12 hours to 9 hours. So that has been a big change.
Yes.
It's been a huge improvement. I think it's helped everyone's mental health as well, like.
Yeah.
Right.
And we tried to avoid it from the start. We discussed it when we started. We were like, oh, it'll be okay, 12 hours. Remember, I voiced my concerns with 12-hour shifts. It's not sustainable long-term. It really drains. So I think everybody's a lot happier back down to the 9 hours.
Yes.
Yeah.
And with this I learned one thing, just because you can do, that does not mean others can do as well.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I always joke with the people in the office here that they have 24 usable hours in a day.
Just because I go home and stare at my teams and make sure everything's running smooth doesn't mean that other people don't have actual lives.
I actually broke my phone and I haven't gotten my new phone fixed. I'm back on my old phone because it makes my wife happy because my old phone doesn't support Teams.
Correct.
Yeah.
Wait, it's so it's so old that it doesn't support Team.
It doesn't have high enough security for F12 to allow me to put teams on it, so.
And that makes sense, that makes sense.
Yeah, and I know this happens.
I'm like, well.
Mm.
Yeah, and I know, and that happens because I guess the device should be in tune joined. And since it's not in tune joined, that's why it happens and old versions are not supported.
Yes.
Yep, it makes my wife happy, so I haven't fixed the new one yet.
Yeah.
Overall, we can see that the productivity has improved, and improvements are being seen across shifts, so that's going good, and...
So call volumes have been all time high in April and that was well managed by the team. And obviously CSAT, that's 100% for everyone. That's really good. I have a knock on the wood. I said touch wood and I did knock on the wood as well.
Yes.
Text it.
So in terms of process and quality, I would say Manuj is the best person for that. He keeps his stick ready behind the text. Just follow, follow, follow, follow, follow SOP, follow SOP. He keeps them checking. So that's there. And that's great. And in terms of transition, so.
Leave Management, which we saw was a bit, I would say, poor or disorganized, that has been better. And that has been a smooth transition within the team. So that's going good.
Okay, moving on to to-dos, no to-dos from previous meeting. And performance analysis, utilization is going good. Everything is on track. Sarah, that's slow because she joined the team in April, then she had some hiccups.
Mhm.
But everything is now settled. She first got ill and then some family emergency came, so she had to take extended leave. And again, Mark being Mark, he was very skeptical. Like, I see this going downstairs. I said, no.
Let's believe that she would be able to do it. And obviously, when Mark said highly about her in my conversation today with him, he spoke highly about her and that's what I see in her. Okay. Now, one thing that Mark made a change like.
Mm.
admin tickets. He has reintroduced people entering time in admin tickets for all the admin tasks they are doing. I know it was there, but we removed it because people were using it not correctly, but again.
Okay.
abused a bit, but with the ones like I've looked through some of them and there's, I think it was Ryder and Kane were helping get Sarah and Up to Speed and Hector as well. So I'm like, well, that makes perfect sense. They're not working on tickets, but they're...
Yeah.
Right.
No.
Mhm.
Yeah.
getting these guys up and running and ready to go. So yeah, as long as they don't start abusing it.
Correct.
It's fine.
Believe me, Kyle.
They won't be able to do it, even if they won't. This guy with the specs who does not use specs, his head uses, so he won't let them do it.
So that's going good. Ticket count, we have seen a dip in that because the changes that we have done is like from 10 A.m. till 5 P.m. they are handling proactive alerts and since these tickets do not close on time.
They take time. That's why we have seen a dip in the tickets. And that's the reason we'll see.
Mm.
Yeah, the closures are down a lot because of the EPDR project as well, because you work on it, but there's some that are stuck at whether the device has been offline for too long or you can't get a hold of the person. So those tickets just kind of drag along. I'm not too concerned about the closure numbers going down a bit.
Yep.
Yeah.
As long as they're hitting their time, I think we're good.
Yep.
Yeah.
And again, I missed one point, so Mark's focus is specifically on quality rather than quantity, and he specifically mentioned I do not want my team to work on alert tickets. I want them to do meaningful work, and I guess he's fighting with you and luck to get more of that, so...
Yes.
Yeah, I see him. Yeah, I see that thing happening. Okay, CSAT, 100%, Keshav got two, Kane 7, Neil 3, Ryder 8, Ripin 8, and Sarah one. So we'll see more service coming in next month.
We're working on it.
No.
and we'll see more of them happening because the transition is over and...
Hmm.
I wanted to add Abhi's data as well, but by the time I pulled the data, matrix was gone. So I could not add his data, otherwise I know CSATs would have been higher.
Yeah.
Okay, leaves, this is the attendance data. So upcoming leaves, 16th and 17th May, Kane 29th May to 2nd June, and Kris 27th to 29th June. These are approved, unplanned, one, Neil one, Sarah 5, and we know that there was...
valid justified reason. Kisha 1.5, Kane 1 and Rider.5. So these were all unplanned leaves. Now we are not going to see much leaves unplanned. Things are controlled. And Mark is making sure like.
Things are moving in a planned way.
Okay, moving on next. And one more thing, like allowable PTO, these are prorated. These are not coming like 22 for everyone. So like Kour joined in March, so 18, Sarah in April 16, and Hector joined in May, so 14.5. So we have made sure of that.
Kip.
S.
Okay, so for the forward, so first thing is call handling discipline. We'll make sure that this is not being missed. There's a strict adherence to it.
And.
Strong coverage remains our point. Mark, you want to say something?
No, all good. Keep going.
Okay, okay, with the shift leads being defined and everything, this would happen, like the shift coverage would be there. Mark is regularly doing ticket checks, spot checks, and he's ensuring that all the tickets are properly updated.
and clear resolution as mentioned in the summary. So that's there. And adherence to L1 SOPs. I know there was some non-adherence being done where the team was not following it, but we are reinforcing that on a regular basis. And we should see a better.
performance overall or I would say not better, consistent performance.
and distribution of tickets and calls across engineers across 3 shifts, that's optimized and we'll make sure that service quality remains consistent. That's our focus, not to increase the workload or not to make any changes now because.
This is going smooth, but we want to make sure that the service quality remains consistent because consistency is one thing that we want to achieve and that's our whole motto.
Okay, this I am ending. Mark, you want to add on anything, specific point which you want to share with me and Natalie? I know you had a call with Kyle yesterday, you already shared everything. Anything you want to add?
Good.
Yeah.
No, Seamus, like you rightly mentioned, right, quality over quantity. So that's what our focus is on. I already shared it with Kyle, but we are going to focus on KT sessions now, knowledge transfer sessions, specifically for the F12 clients who are working 24-7.
So Kyle, that's going to be my focus for the entire month, right? To catch up and collaborate with the rest of the ISTTLs and, you know, host those sessions and whatnot to make the team successful.
Mhm.
Good, yep.
The.
right? I know they are not going to grasp everything, but if we are able to grasp 80 to 90% of that knowledge, right, we should be golden.
Yep, I think it's going to be good. I look forward to them getting a little extra knowledge bump from these.
Right, right. I've already.
Especially some of the weird ones, like we've got one client that's in the UK, one's in Germany, we've got somebody in Australia. I'm like, well, these people are all over the place. So any boost in knowledge for those clients is definitely going to help out.
Yeah.
Right.
Ms.
Correct. Apart from that, sorry, go ahead.
I think.
No, please go ahead, ma. You finish your thought.
The next item, big item on my list is to make sure Sarah and Hector, they actually settled down in our environment, right?
They are new to the process and that's what takes most of the time and the toll, Kyle, right? So just be patient on that, right? I'm going to keep on working with these folks and just get them up to speed. I'm using Ryder and Cane and Ripon, all three of them at the same time, right? And hence you would see
Mm.
Kip.
And.
the ADMIN time or the training time for them going up, right?
Yeah.
Yep.
but not at the cost of alerts being delayed or anything like that.
Yeah.
Good, good.
Kyle, do you see, and I'm not talking about right now, in next three to four months, I want to ask specifically.
Do you see this team increasing or more ticks getting added because of some extra work or something like that? I'm just trying to do a forecasting. And that's what I want to ask. And I'll tell you one basic reason behind it after you tell me.
The next three months, probably not. In the future, potentially, yes.
Yeah, and I'll tell you the reason why I have been seeing Mark. What happens on weekends, we, and this is 1 classic thing that happens with the roster. We cannot put two people on the same option, the same shift, whether it's a weekday or a weekend.
Now what that happens is, and we do not, and I was working with Mark on the data, he was preparing data and everything. We do not have a specific call volume on weekends. It can be high on one Saturday, it can be high on next Sunday. Now what that does is if we distribute week off.
Yeah.
It would be Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, and Friday, Saturday. Now, if the volume goes high on weekend, specifically between 8 and 5, I would say. Now, and in that case, and this can be a genuine thing that happens, one person takes an off.
Uh, sickly or anything.
Mhm.
Then there's only one tick left.
And in that case, it would bring a toll on Mark. He would have to log in and everything wherein he would, instead of doing administration work, checking all the things are in place and everything, he would have to log in and take calls. And I know initial expectation was like Manuj would have to fill in this and he is ready to do that.
He hasn't raised any concern.
But this also brings in a challenge that Mark is unable to strategize for the team what next he can do.
and he is unable to grow this team with this challenge. And I know because it's not one tech, it should be 3 techs who would be adding because we need techs in all the shifts. So, or maybe 2 techs need to be added because two shifts need to be covered. So this is one of the...
reasons I see a challenge coming in future because we cannot say that, okay, it's a weekend, you cannot get sick.
Hmm.
Yeah.
So, and that can be a genuine thing.
Being sick is a choice, right?
The.
Yeah.
I wish it was. But yeah, like I could see, like not probably not in the next three months, but I could see adding at least one more just to boost the weekend a little bit. During the week, it's more proactive projects that they'd be working on during the day shift. So likely we don't need another tech.
So.
during the week on Saturday, like you got 3 on Sunday for the morning, then 2 in the afternoon. I can see putting another one on so that we have a second Saturday morning or a third Saturday morning tech.
And depending on what the trends for the volume are.
maybe an additional one that we can work Saturday, Sunday in the afternoon. So we have three there as well. But
I think for now, like it hasn't been too, too bad. Knock on wood again. Hopefully it's like we've had some some pretty rough days, but we've made it through.
But I think...
Down the road a bit, we probably will expand the team, but I don't think we're at that point just yet.
Okay, got it. I saw this because when, because I specifically asked for the roster, I am not concerned about Ian and Russell, but I do need to see like what techs are doing, which if they are aligned, just in case if Mark is not available, I am.
Okay.
able to cover that up and see and follow. And that's where I saw and Mark also flagged it like this is this can be a serious day. And then I asked him to check the call volus and everything. He said like it's scattered. We cannot predict it the way the calls are there.
Yeah.
Yeah, this is really all over the map. Like, there's no consistency at all.
And I trust what Mark says.
Okay.
But like, there's enough consistency that Saturday morning gets the three weekend texts, because there's usually a bit higher volume then. We've got that covered. But again, there's, it could be some random day. It could be a Tuesday at 2 in the morning, and now the phone's ringing off the hook.
Why? Well, we gotta figure it out. But there's not enough consistency to warrant just...
Having an extra tech at all times.
Right.
Yeah.
It's so scattered, it's...
It's a bit tough to gauge where they need to be.
Again, like going down the road a bit, we probably will need to expand the team, but...
And...
No, and...
But we'll see how that goes.
Yeah, and I would like to specifically ask one question, Kyle, because I know I could have asked Mark, but he won't be able to answer it. Because that's the other side of the business. Initially, when we started this team, and in midway, Lakhwinder said that I'm not able to read the benefits out of this team.
Just.
I'm not able to show my leadership that this is a benefit that we are getting by investing such huge amount. Now, are you able to see or Lakhwinder is able to see that benefit putting in this team? Are we able to actually...
Get benefit out of this thing.
I think we've turned the corner on that one. We're starting to see more benefit from it. Again, with the change from the 12 hours to the 9 hour shift and being 24-7, having somebody on, it's opening us up to be able to do the proactive projects outside of the after hours so that they're not
Blake.
waiting for phone calls and having to drop it.
all that. So I think we are starting to see the benefit.
Vince.
If we can keep up the pace on some of these projects, like, we're heavy on the EPDR right now. Let me get that down to a manageable number so we can pass it back to the ISPs to maintain.
We've done a good job on the missing EPDRs. We're now pushing for the failing ones, which that's going to take a lot more brain power on the tech side. So we'll see how we do on that. If we can push through that nice and quick, we can get that over to the ISD, we can get them some more projects.
Yep.
We can cycle the guys through like every once the schedule changes. We'll get a new crew on the day shift, teach them new things. They can relay that information across the rest of the team. And I think we're really starting to be able to show that benefit because we are actioning these projects a lot quicker.
Right.
Okay, so I just want to know whether we are able to derive our ROI from having this team because initially that was the biggest challenge that we had. Again.
Yeah.
We also need to see the business aspect, just not that we are maintaining coverage. And I know that does not fall in Mark's area, so I never discussed that with him. This falls more on your end, left in this area. So happy to hear that we are able to read ROI from it. Natalie, you want to say anything?
Which?
Yeah.
You gonna?
Oh, great. Natalie does not have to say anything. That's the biggest thing for her.
Is that is that good news for you guys? No.
Yep.
Mark's crushing it, so that's all I care about.
Great.
Thanks, Mark. Thanks, Kyle. Thanks for your time. We'll meet next month. Have a great day.
Bye.
Thank you.
Yep.
You do, right?
Yeah.